yesterday I was talking to someone I love very much
who is sick
andy rice you know who was
george bush's foreign minister
who is an absolutely remarkable woman
she told me but you understand us
in the United States
we have a different conception of immigration
I say it's not true
what is the difference between the united states and you
on the east coast
you-are protected
by eight thousand kilometers of Atlantic
it is not crossed by swimming
on the west coast
you-are protected
by twelve thousand kilometers of Pacific
it is not crossed by swimming
at the top you have the north pole
it is not crossed by foot
and in the south you have the mexico
and you made three thousand kilometers of barbed wire
what are you teaching us?
you can come on foot through the Greek border
to Turks on foot
and the Mediterranean at its widest
must be less than a thousand kilometers long
and the gilberta strait
twelve kilometers ago
with a dress that permanently receives shares
of
while europe is the continent
the most generous in the world
go try to settle in canada
or in the United States without the seed card
and you will see
finally listen I remind you
that until another ten years if you had AIDS
you don't like the right to go to the states
except that the United States has its borders
they are airports
ours
we have a gemeility
with africa